okay so we are covering something that a
lot of people have asked for recently
and honestly i didn't actually know it
was a thing until you guys asked for it
marvel team up number 14 written by
robert kirkman which is when invincible
meets spider-man and the avengers yes
this is a cool thing this kind of comes
off the heels of the story that was part
of invincible where mark was fighting
angstrom levy and he was sending him
through different dimensions and when he
came out of one dimension you saw like
the webbing of spider-man following him
right so this is basically that story
what happened in that universe which is
kind of awesome right because you have
spider-man and you've got doctor octopus
who are basically fighting each other
and in the midst of all that you have
like the portal that angstrom levy
opened up that sends mark flying through
it and of course as soon as he comes in
here he immediately bumps into uh dr
octopus kind of incapacitates him for a
split second and then following that
it's one of those things where
spider-man doesn't really know who it is
but his thought is that it is nova
now of course mark's response having no
idea what's going on here is like hey oh
my god i'm so sorry i did not mean to
hit that guy i i did not mean to to
knock that guy down is it going to be
okay and the response to spider-man's
like no he's good man he's been trying
to kill me so no no we're cool
that's one of the things i love here
right now one of the things to know a
little bit of a little thing for a lot
of you guys who are not familiar kirkman
actually got his first real big break in
marvel comics writing marvel zombies so
it makes sense that he would be able to
one do a crossover between invincible
and uh and and marvel or really
spider-man and two he's written
spider-man before so i like the way he
writes spider-man right he writes with
just kind of like this this sort of you
know everything's sort of cool until
it's not kind of attitude right now of
course dr octopus comes too and
immediately starts attacking like
spider-man and mark again and this fight
this fight's literally how many panels
three three panels long
it's three panels long like literally he
snatches up dr octopus and like yanks
him in into like this opening beats the
crap out of him and he's like okay that
guy's not gonna hurt anybody for a few
hours um i think we're all good then the
cops show up and spider-man's like let's
get out of here so one of the funny
things here is he he almost kind of
offers him a really offers them to give
him a kind of tour of the area but the
first thing is to find out what his deal
is and then that's this that's kind of
normal right when it comes to like these
crossover events you get the the kind of
tour right where they get to meet each
other they get to know each other all
that kind of stuff you've seen it like
batman punisher and all that kind of
good stuff and so it's kind of funny
because mark actually flies spider-man
up to the up to a roof and he's like
look i don't really need the help man i
can kind of do it on my own but that's
when they kind of get the break down
right you know spider-man gets the whole
explanation from a couple different ways
right one spider-man explains to mark
that that villain was doctor octopus
right he's basically a bad guy that he's
really really dangerous so if anything
mark did him a favor by facing off
against him and then kind of explains
his story right you know like well i've
got spider powers you know the
proportional strength of a spider
different things like that but a lot of
the explanation really comes from mark
and in truth that makes the most sense
because whenever you read these
crossover stories there's only ever
really the most interest in one
particular character right it's never
really like a 50 50 split like yes we
get to see like spider-man and
invincible meat instead the question
usually falls along the lines of what's
mark gonna be like when he meets
spider-man how's mark going to react
what's mark going to say that's usually
how these kind of responses work and
that's why you get a lot of explanation
and exposition coming from mark now in
truth this is all stuff that we already
know but for those of you guys who are
kind of new here who were unfamiliar
with the invincible mythos i don't know
why you'd click on this if you weren't
but if you're unfamiliar with the
invincible mythos the idea here is that
mark is basically the son of omni man
this guy from an alien world called
viltrum right and the viltromites are
basically a planet full of superman
except they're evil and so the idea of
omniman was to conquer the world and
that once mark realized what was going
on his powers came to fruition a massive
fight broke out between the two and
mark's dad realizing how much he cared
about him ended up leaving but mark's
mom basically realized her husband was
basically a villain hell bent on
conquering the world this is after he
killed a multitude of superheroes and
then in turn this is really just kind of
mark dealing with the aftermath of it
right now of course angstrom levy being
the villain that basically came from an
alternate reality and was looking to
amass an army of marks but also get rid
of invincible and so this guy having a
mastery over over you know dimensional
barriers and things like that it's cool
right it's pretty interesting but with
that kind of big explanation out of the
way literally mark's like yeah man my
life's pretty rough at the moment and
peter parker's like well i mean i know
what it's like to lose family right like
i know what it's like to lose you know
my my uncle different things like that
you know but nonetheless once the two
are acquainted spider-man just based on
his own life experiences and so on and
so forth basically gets the feel that
like this guy's not a villain right
mark's a pretty cool guy right
invincible he's a good guy there's not
really anything you know about him
that's nefarious so that they really
need to worry about and so at that point
mark's kind of like i mean what's what's
your name you know i don't know what
your name is and he's like my name's
spiderman and he's like i mean
okay you know i mean you couldn't think
of a better name than that like that
name's kind of lame isn't it like
spider-man like spider guy in in reality
spider-man one is one of the coolest
names ever but then like when spider-man
asked him like well what's your name
he's like invincible and he's like okay
well then whatever man so like
at that point uh the two of them just
kind of like they almost hit it off
right like they seem like they'd be
really really cool friends and he was
like oh he's like okay let me take you
to to meet these guys let me take you to
the avengers right you can hang out with
them you can meet them we could try to
find a way to find you back home you
know all that kind of cool stuff and so
when they get there uh one you see of
course aunt may who's basically there
and then of course you see mary jane
watson who's who's there and they're all
kind of hanging out and you know talking
and whatnot and mj's like well we're
supposed to have a movie night he's like
well i'll put him in the middle of
something and then in turn of course he
takes him to meet the avengers and
that's kind of a cool thing it's because
seeing mark encounter the avengers is
kind of amazing right because here's the
real question you have to ask here's a
question i want to know from you guys
right i want an answer to this question
from you guys do you think mark would
make a good addition to the avengers do
you think mark should be on the avengers
team not would it be cool if he was do
you think he would be a good avenger
because we can all agree it'd be cool if
he was on the avengers no one's saying
man it would suck if mark was on the
avengers team right no one out there is
saying that and if they are saying that
they're just looking for a reason to be
mad it would be amazing if mark was on
the on on the avengers team having said
that do you think he'd make a good
addition to the team now when he meets
them he's like okay so you guys look
really really good he's like okay don't
say anything let me guess what your
names are right he's like so so that guy
was spider-man so he's like okay iron
man like he refers to iron man as robot
man wolverine he calls him claw man and
then like captain america he calls him
flag man which is not the worst name
there ever was for captain america let's
be honest man and then like like the
century he calls him fabio man which i
love
i adore that and then like like bat
woman that's what he refers to spider to
to jessica drew as right spider woman
and then he gets to and then he gets to
luke cage and then he gets the luke cage
you all know what's coming he calls luke
cage black man and it's like
2003 was a different time guys like this
this was this isn't really 2003 this is
more like this is more like 2005 2006.
it was a different time right it was a
different time period right we weren't
all wearing our hearts on our sleeves so
uh the funny thing about this is that
you have like you know mark who's just
kind of looked at as a goof by the
avengers you know and so you have iron
man is like i'm picking up on something
on the the police broadband whatever you
know like uh it's a guy with metal
spider arms that's basically terror you
know tearing stuff up at the harbor and
so in response spiderman's like okay
cool you know me and mark we got this
doctor octopus you know we're cool but
it's kind of funny to see like mark
meeting the avengers i love the
encounter luke cage walks off and he's
like black you know like like he just he
walks off i think it's kind of hilarious
but when you end up having these guys
basically arriving to uh to doctor
octopus the fight's pretty
straightforward right i mean it's it's a
pretty straightforward conflict in the
sense that like you know dr octopus is
like yeah you know i'm gonna take out
you and your friends and you know we're
gonna call it a day mark beats the crap
out of him right he beats the absolute
tar out of him and actually like tears
his legs apart but here's the cool thing
and this is one of the things to
understand about this most of the
crossovers that you see between marvel
and dc or marvel and others usually have
a pretty complex plot the idea behind
kirkman doing this if i had to wager a
guess it didn't need to be complex when
people were reading or people saw that
there was going to be a crossover
between invincible and spider-man what
they wanted was a fun comic that's what
they wanted right this is especially
during a time when marvel's experiencing
all that upheaval right that's why the
avengers roster looks the way it does
because it's really the new avengers
more so than it's the actual avengers
but people just want to have fun right
people just wanted to read a fun
crossover between spider-man and
invincible it's not overly complex it's
pretty straightforward pretty simple and
that's basically it and that's what we
got right that's what we get here right
and so basically the day kind of winds
down the whole situation winds down the
cops show back up they end up arresting
doctor octopus and then the portal
starts to reopen and then and then like
mark's like okay man like you know he's
doing this to try to weaken me right
angstrom levy's trying to make me weaker
by sitting through all these different
dimensions and so on and so forth and
then what's probably one of the most
disappointing moments of the whole story
that you have like you have mark who's
like okay the portal's open it was
awesome meeting you spider-man
spider-man's like hey man it was awesome
meeting you mark's like okay i gotta get
out of here go back to my dimension you
know wish me luck and spider-man's like
wait man maybe i could help and then
like attaches webbing to to mark as soon
as the mark passes through the webbing
shuts off or the the portal closes which
is how the webbing got stuck in
invincible's universe but it's kind of
disappointing man because i'm gonna be
honest with you guys i kind of would
like to have seen spider-man in
invincibles invincibles universe and you
might say right you would you might say
that spider-man in the invincible verse
would suck no he wouldn't man because of
the spider-sense this spider-sense is
the thing that would help him stay on
top i mean if he's fighting like freddie
mercury sure he would get absolutely
pummeled if he was fighting like omniman
sure he would get pommel but if he's
fighting like anybody else i mean it
would be cool man like would you guys
want to see spider-man appear in the
invincible verse let me know down in the
comment section but with that being said
guys again pretty short pretty fun
pretty simple story that's all it needed
to be was just fun right that's all it
had to be which is fun but we're gonna
bring this to an end fyi i am taking off
all of next week i need a break i am
mentally exhausted i'm gonna take a trip
to boston and i'm gonna do some street
photography and i'm probably gonna
attach a gopro to my chest and just
record the whole experience and probably
upload that on my personal channel uh i
have no idea but i just need a time to
just kind of break and relax not focus
on work not focus on trying to grow two
brands
just chill but anyway guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace
you